[Applaudissements]
quoi salud à sayoun ac alors c'est une
star internationale sai luna sinon
j'adore ce titre à wimbledon 6
[Applaudissements]
comme tu connais ans l'espagnol telmo tu
connais ans l'espagnol chez colette au
final
eh ouais
[Applaudissements]
m
mais qui quoi qui l'a jamais les pépites
all he will et pépito au mexique
oui je m'en demandez mon jeu elle n'ose
dire celui-là il pense qu'à manger su à
son ami ce n'existe pas au mexique les
appareils sur un autre elle est très
sympa dit que tu es d'origine mexicaine
mexicaine j'adore mais que mexique
cancun
mais là bas geo aqua gym aquagym témoin
soit hulot n'a je devais y trouve
exceptionnel franchement j'adore le
titre le pied à la finale à ça veut dire
quoi à la souffrance et à l'as à l'avion
de la viande halal ça dure gdl pour ceux
dont c'est halal ou à l'as à la stas
them'all aller voler ni boulot les ailes
bien sûr aulas à la
à l'as bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
huacho salaces mucho salaces et iloveyou
you are formidable à like you d'ailleurs
parce que l impôt shon what you were all
by cale à cale à cale à 10h à 18 ans
plus tôt bon alors qu'elle en a 12 13
sens et a2 et bien c'est bien
derrière podium